Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und diese Sendung ist insofern eine kleine Ausnahme, als dass sie diesmal nahtlos an die Sendung davor anschließt. Wir hatten dort ausführlich gesprochen mit Joachim Trümper, der Projektleiter des ROSAT-Satelliten. Und dort ging es viel um Röntgen, Astronomie und natürlich vor allem um das Projekt selbst. Gegen Ende des Gesprächs wurde auch noch mal herausgestellt, dass dieser spezifische Satellit ein kleines Problem hat. Er befindet sich zwar noch im Orbit, aber in einem sehr niedrigen Orbit und sucht so langsam den Weg wieder zurück zur Erde, tut das aber nicht so in dem kontrollierten Maß, wie das vielleicht wünschenswert wäre. Und um genau dieses Thema jetzt noch mal aufzugreifen, bin ich heute zum DLR nach Bonn gefahren und begrüße als Gesprächspartner für die heutige Sendung Manuel, Manuel Metz.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wo sind wir hier genau? Welche Abteilung bekleidest du beim DLR?
Ja, wir sind hier beim DLR Raumfahrtmanagement. Ich bin in der Abteilung Technologie für Raumfahrtsysteme und Robotik.
Raumfahrtmanagement, was muss man sich darunter vorstellen?
Ja, das DLR Raumfahrtmanagement ist durch ein Gesetz, das sogenannte Raumfahrtaufgabenübertragungsgesetz, von der Bundesregierung damit beauftragt, das deutsche Raumfahrtprogramm umzusetzen. Das heißt, hier in dem Hause werden Projekte verwirklicht. Die deutschen Raumfahrtprojekte, Satellitenmission, nationale Satellitenmissionen werden hier umgesetzt. Aber auch die Gelder, beispielsweise die Bundesrepublik, die Bundesregierung bei der ESA einsetzt für Satellitenmissionen, werden von hier aus gesteuert.
Und wie hieß die Abteilung noch gleich?
Technologie für Raumfahrtssysteme und Robotik.
Technologie für Raumfahrtssysteme und Robotik. Und wie viele andere Abteilungen gibt es da noch? Wie teilt sich das hier so auf, um eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen?
Ja, die meisten Abteilungen beschäftigen sich hier mit spezifischen Anwendungen, zum Beispiel Erdbeobachtungsthemen, wo dann Sensorik für Erdbeobachtungen entwickelt wird. Themen wie Extragalaktik, also man schaut weit in das Weltall hinein. Navigationsthemen zum Beispiel. Das sind meistens so aufgabenspezifische Themen, die hier behandelt werden.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Forschung, sondern es ist mehr die Durchführung.
Richtig, es ist hauptsächlich das Management der Projekte.
Und was ist jetzt vielleicht mal so bei dir noch mal kurz angefangen? Welchen Weg hast du genommen, um hier zu landen?
Ich bin kein Luft- und Raumfahrt-Ingenieur. Ich habe Physik studiert mit dem Schwerpunkt Astronomie, habe dann auch in der Astronomie promoviert. Und habe mich dann hier beworben auf eine Stelle, die sich mit dem Schwerpunkt einerseits Weltraummüll, andererseits auch Satellitentechnologien allgemein beschäftigt. Aber mein Schwerpunkt ist im Moment tatsächlich dieses Thema Weltraummüll.
Weltraummüll haben wir ja auch hier bei Raumzeit schon mal besprochen, mit Holger Krag vom ESOK in Darmstadt. Inwiefern bist du da regelmäßig mit beschäftigt?
Oh, das ist eigentlich ein dauerndes Thema. Also zum einen fördern wir bestimmte Forschungsanrichtungen, Universitäten, zum Beispiel die Technische Universität Braunschweig, Fraunhofer-Institut, Ernst-Mach-Institut in Freiburg, die von uns Fördergelder bekommen. Das heißt, ich stehe mit den Forschern dort auf direkten Kontakt. Andererseits auch bin ich in verschiedenen internationalen Gremien tätig, die sich auch mit der Problematik Weltraummüll beschäftigen.
Und seid ihr dann auch mit der ESA da in direkter Verbindung?
Ja, genau. Also auch da mit dem Space Debris Office am ESOK in Darmstadt sind wir da in direkter Verbindung. Wir treffen uns regelmäßig in diesen Gremien und auch sonst haben wir öfters direkten Kontakt.
Auch wenn es halt so ein bisschen um Weltraumschrott geht, wollen wir das Thema jetzt nicht komplett an der Stelle bei AA aufnehmen. Da lohnt es sich dann für den geneigten und interessierten Zuhörer vielleicht auch nochmal in Ausgabe Nummer 7 reinzuhorchen. Aber was ja, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile so es in den Mainstream schafft, es gibt einfach grundsätzlich diese Problematik, dass es da oben schon sehr voll geworden ist und vor allem, dass man eben sich lange, lange Zeit wenig Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, was denn mal nach dem Ende der Mission mit dem ganzen Zeug so stattfindet. Da gibt es dann, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieses verklärte Bild mit, naja, das taucht dann in die Atmosphäre ein und dann ist es wieder weg, verglüht schön und so, so ein bisschen wie auch mit dem normalen Müll. Da denkt man ja auch immer so, der wird so verbrannt und dann ist er weg. Das stimmt ja auch nicht so ganz. Jetzt haben wir ja diesen konkreten Fall des ROSAT-Satelliten, der Anfang der 90er-Jahre gestartet wurde, dann auch eine sehr viel längere Laufzeit hatte, als das ursprünglich so erwartet werden konnte. Inwiefern steht denn jetzt dieser Satellit im Mittelpunkt des Tages?
Es ist nun tatsächlich so, dass dieser Satellit Anfang der 90er gestartet wurde auf ein Orbit von 580 Kilometern. Es gibt dort immer noch eine Restatmosphäre, eine sehr dünne Restatmosphäre, die dazu führt, dass die Bahnhöhe des Satelliten langsam, aber kontinuierlich absinkt. Er ist aktuell Ende August, hat er jetzt eine Höhe von etwa 300 Kilometern erreicht.
Ende August 2011, vielleicht wird ja diese Sendung auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört, wer weiß es so genau. Wie hoch, sagst du?
Etwa 300 Kilometer.
Klingt ja jetzt erstmal noch nicht so dramatisch viel weniger, ist ja noch nicht mal die Hälfte, aber irgendwann geht es dann immer schneller bergab.
Genau, es wird immer schneller bergab gehen. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass die Atmosphäre, je tiefer man der Satellit kommt, umso dichter wird die Atmosphäre. Das kann man sehen an der Abstiegsrate, die er hat. Also Anfang 2009 war die Abstiegsrate, naja, so Größenordnung 25 Meter pro Tag. Also er hat 25 Meter an Höhe pro Tag verloren. Anfang August waren wir schon bei etwa 350 Metern pro Tag, sprich alle drei Tage ein Kilometer Höhenverlust. Jetzt sind wir bereits drüber, etwa bei 400 Metern pro Tag. Das wird langsam weiter annehmen, diese Abstiegsrate. Bis der Satellit dann, ja, eine Höhe von 150 Kilometern zum Beispiel erreicht, dann wird er wahrscheinlich nur noch einen Tag im Orbit bleiben, wenn er dann eine Höhe von etwa 120 Kilometern erreicht hat, dann hat er nur noch einen Überlebensdauer von einem Orbit. Das heißt, zum Schluss wird dieser Einfluss der Atmosphäre immer stärker und er geht dann irgendwann einfach über von diesem Orbit, das heißt die Erde einmal umrunden, wird er dann in so einer Art freien Fall übergehen und dann tatsächlich recht schnell wieder eintreten.
Wie genau lässt sich das jetzt so prognostizieren, wann genau das sein wird?
Das kann man recht, man kann es nur mit einer großen Unsicherheit prognostizieren. Die liegt im Moment bei etwa 20 Prozent. Das ist so ein gewisser Erfahrungswert, dass die Restlebensdauer auf etwa 20 Prozent genau bestimmt werden kann. Das heißt, im Moment, die Vorhersagen lauten oder die Prognose ist, dass der Satellit Anfang November wieder eintreten wird. Wir haben im Moment Ende August bis Anfang November. Und die Unsicherheit beträgt im Moment etwa plus minus 14 Tage.
Die Unsicherheit?
Die Unsicherheit. Wo ist man sich denn da so unsicher? Man weiß halt eben letztendlich nicht, auf welchem Orbit genau der Satellit herunterkommen wird. Das hat eigentlich zwei Gründe. Das eine ist, dass die Modelle der Atmosphäre, die man benutzt, um diese Lebensdauer zu berechnen, eine gewisse intrinsische Unsicherheit haben. Und der größte Unsicherheitsfaktor ist die Sonnenaktivität. Die Sonnenaktivität hat Einfluss auf unsere Atmosphäre. Die Sonnenaktivität geht von Regionen in der Nähe der Sonnenflecken aus. Und von dort geht Strahlung aus, die von der Erdatmosphäre absorbiert wird, was zu einem Ausdehnen der Erdatmosphäre führt. Und damit zu einer Änderung der Dichte der Atmosphäre, durch die der Satellit gerade fliegt.
Das heißt, die Erde, man muss sich das vorstellen, die atmet sozusagen so ein bisschen aus in dem Moment, wo die Sonnenaktivität besonders stark ist. Und dann wächst die Atmosphäre in den Raum. Und wenn der Sonnenwind nicht so stark ist, atmet ein sozusagen und schwillt an.
Ja, genau, so in etwa. Das ist nicht unbedingt der Sonnenwind, das ist tatsächlich die Ultraviolettstrahlung oder die Extrem-Ultraviolettstrahlung, die dort einfach zu einer Aufheizung der oberen Atmosphäre führen.
Okay, also ein klimatisches Problem sozusagen.
Genau, sozusagen. Und die Erdatmosphäre reagiert halt eben darauf, etwas verzögert reagiert sie, aber sie verzögert auf die Aktivität der Sonne. Die Sonne macht das eigentlich relativ regelmäßig in einem Zyklus von elf Jahren. In einem Zyklus von elf Jahren wächst diese Aktivität an. Es kommen mehr Sonnenflecken und dann geht sie wieder runter. Wir sind im Moment in der Situation, dass die Sonne nicht das tut, was man von ihr erwartet hat. Dieser Sonnenzyklus ist im Moment verzögert. Das heißt, er hat später eingesetzt, als man erwartet hat, als die Modelle vorhergesagt haben. Das hat auch zu einer Verzögerung geführt.
Das hält den Satelliten noch mehr auf der Bahn, als man das jetzt so vorhersagen hätte können.
Genau, zumindest, als man es vor einigen Jahren hätte vorhersagen können.
Der Einfluss scheint ja jetzt nicht ganz unerheblich zu sein. Ich meine, 20 Prozent...
Was man halt eben angeben kann, ist tatsächlich so eine Art Mittelwert. Das ist der wahrscheinlichste Wert. Wie gesagt, diese 20 Prozent Unsicherheit ist so die Größenordnung, wo man wirklich mit rechnen muss, dass man um diese 20 Prozent schief liegt. Letztendlich, weil man nicht weiß, was die Sonne machen wird.
Aber selbst wenn die Sonne sich jetzt vollständig zurückhält, dass das Ding in diesem Jahr runterkommt, das ist klar. Oder auch das nicht unbedingt?
Also ich würde jetzt mal wagen zu behaupten, dass er tatsächlich wohl noch dieses Jahr tatsächlich wieder eintreten wird.
Wo genau befindet sich denn der Satellit eigentlich? Also was war so der ursprüngliche Orbit, wo flog der entlang?
Also der ursprüngliche Orbit, das war auf 580 Kilometern Höhe mit einer Inklination von 53 Grad. Inklination ist die Bahnneigung der Flugbahn des Satelliten gegenüber dem Equator.
Also wäre es 0 Grad, würde er den Equator entlang fliegen?
Genau, würde er den Equator entlang fliegen, bei 90 Grad würde er genau über die Pole fliegen.
Und 53 ist schon mehr Polorientiert als Equator orientiert.
Ja genau.
Geringfügig.
Geringfügig, ja genau. Das heißt auch, dass der Satellit, also diese 53 Grad sind auch die, ist der Breitengrad, den der Satellit maximal erreicht.
Verstehe, das heißt, er kommt sehr hoch. 53er Breitengrad ist dann bis wohin?
Knapp südlich von Hamburg. Das heißt, er fliegt immer wieder hin und her, von uns aus gesehen quasi immer hin und her zwischen 53 Grad Nord und Süd. Ja, das ist so sein Orbit.
Das heißt, genau genommen könnte er eigentlich auch überall runterkommen, bis zu dieser Höhe oder könnte er vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen weiter fliegen.
Er könnte überall runterkommen. Es ist so, dass dieser Orbit nicht in sich geschlossen ist. Also wenn er einmal die Erde umrundet hat, wenn man sich das mal vorstellen möchte, dass man also die Bodenspur dort, wo der Satellit drüber fliegt, mit einem Stift markiert oder wie auch immer da eine imaginäre Linie zieht, dann ist beim nächsten Überflug dieser Überflug über den Äquator verschoben. Weil die Erde sich ja immer weiter dreht. Genau, das passiert bei jedem Überflug. Und im Endeffekt überstreich der Satellit so quasi die gesamte Mantelfläche, die zwischen diesen beiden Ringen liegt, zwischen plus 53 Grad und minus 53 Grad. Und im Moment, da wir so eine große Unsicherheit haben, muss man quasi sagen, irgendwo dazwischen wird er runterfallen.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht besonders präzise.
Das ist im Moment nicht besonders präzise, ja. Wir haben im Moment wieder Eintrittsraten von etwa 60 bis 80 Tonnen Material, Weltraummüll, Satelliten, Raketen, Oberstufen pro Jahr.
Pro Jahr?
60 bis 80 Tonnen pro Jahr. In der gesamten Raumfahrtgeschichte, seit dem Start des Sputnik, sind 27.000 Tonnen in den Orbit gebracht worden und wieder eingetreten. Etwas mehr als 27.000 Tonnen in der Zwischenzeit. Wenn man das mal umrechnet, ist das für diesen Zeitraum eine Eintrittsrate von sogar 600 Tonnen pro Jahr. Das war vor allen Dingen so die Zeit des Kalten Krieges, wo sehr viele Überwachungssatelliten, Aufklärungssatelliten gestartet wurden, dass sie auch alle irgendwann wieder runterkommen mussten. Also von daher, dieses Problem besteht schon länger. Aufgrund der etwas niedrigeren Startraten sind die Wiedereintrittsraten im Moment halt eben niedriger. Wie gesagt, bei etwa 60 bis 80 Tonnen pro Jahr.
Aber das meiste davon verglüht auch tatsächlich.
Richtig, das meiste verglüht. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass ein Satellit, der wieder eintritt, dass dort etwa 60 bis 90 Prozent in der oberen Erdatmosphäre verglüht.
Und bei diesem Versuchs-Satelliten jetzt, der ist so klein, dass er nicht viel erledigt.
Richtig, das sind also gerade diese kleineren Missionen. Die sind so klein, da wird kaum etwas überleben.
Und die größeren Missionen, die jetzt also auch mit nennenswerterem Material nach oben gehen und nicht vollständig verglühen werden, aller Voraussicht nach, die haben dann aber in der Regel tatsächlich ein Antriebssystem noch mit dabei. Oder sollten eins haben.
Bei aktuellen Missionen, da ist es so, dass eine Risikoanalyse gemacht wird. Also man schaut sich den Satelliten vorher an, untersucht, wie er eintreten wird, was voraussichtlich verglühen wird, was nicht. Und setzt dann ein Kriterium an. Bei uns ist es so, dass dieses Kriterium ist 1 zu 10.000. Und zwar eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 10.000, dass irgendein Mensch auf der gesamten Erdoberfläche getroffen werden könnte. Wenn dieses Kriterium verletzt wird, dann muss man Gegenmaßnahmen treffen.
Das heißt, wenn es eine Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt von 1 zu 10.000, dass einer von den 6 Milliarden eine Schraube auf den Kopf kriegt, dann muss man sich sozusagen um die Schraube aktivieren. Genau. Wie wahrscheinlich ist denn das? Ich weiß nicht, 1 zu 10.000, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also ist das so etwas, was man selten reißt? Oder ist das schon etwas, worum man sich eigentlich jetzt fast immer Gedanken machen muss? Das hat ja auch so ein bisschen was mit der Verteilung der Menschen auf diesem Planeten zu tun. Wie groß ist denn so die potenzielle Aufschlagswahrscheinlichkeit? Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo auf diesem Planeten was fallen lasse, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich da einen Menschen treffe, ist wahrscheinlich nicht 1 zu 10.000, oder?
Wenn man irgendwo auf der Erde etwas fallen lässt.
Also wenn ich jetzt so im Orbit schwebe und könnte jetzt theoretisch jeden beliebigen Bereich erreichen und ich würde da sozusagen aus dem Nichts eine Bowlingkugel fallen lassen.
Dann wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit wohl geringer als 1 zu 10.000. Das hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, wie groß dann letztendlich das ist, was unten ankommt. Also wenn es nur eine Schraube ist oder so, die man irgendwo fallen lässt, da passiert nicht. Die wird es nicht schaffen, genau. Letztendlich hängt es dann von der Größe und von der Masse ab des Objektes, das runterkommt. Das heißt, wenn man dieses Kriterium bei der Analyse reißt, dann muss man halt eben schauen, dass man das Risiko minimieren kann.
Wie sieht es denn jetzt bei dem ROSAT konkret aus? Was ist denn da drin?
Der ROSAT ist zunächst erstmal ein mehr oder weniger normaler Satellit. Da sind Elektronikboxen drin, Aluboxen, Strukturen, die einfach diesen Satelliten zusammenhalten. Er hat natürlich Solarpanele. Was den ROSAT etwas besonders macht, ist sein Teleskop. Das hat Herr Drümper ja auch bereits angesprochen. Dieser Wolterspiegel, der dort verbaut ist, besteht aus Cerrodur. Das ist eine hitzebeständige Glaskeramik, die man auch auf modernen Kochfeldern findet. Dieser Wolterspiegel ist umgeben von einer Struktur, die ihn hält. Diese Struktur hält das Ganze zusammen. Das heißt, dass wir da jetzt ein Objekt haben, das insgesamt 2,4 Tonnen wiegt. Also dieser gesamte Satellit wiegt 2,4 Tonnen. Das heißt also, dieser Spiegel, diese Struktur, die ihn hält, dass die Instrumente, die etwa 400 Kilo gewogen haben, unter dem Drumherum diese Elektronik boxen und was dann noch alles dazugehört.
Und ist jetzt eigentlich nur der Spiegel das Problem oder ist es vor allem der Spiegel oder auch der Spiegel?
Für den ROSAT konkret ist es vor allem der Spiegel in Kombination mit der CFK-Umwandlung.
Weil er auch extrem hitzebeständig ist?
CFK ist nicht direkt hitzebeständig, aber CFK ist so eine Art, man nennt das ein Applator. Ein Applator ist ein Material, was man auch beim Wiedereintritt von Raumkapseln beispielsweise verwendet, beim einmaligen Wiedereintritt. Es ist so, dass dieses CFK besteht aus diesen Kohlefasermatten, die sind verklebt mit einem Harz. Wenn jetzt der Satellit wieder eintritt, dann fängt dieses Harz an, aus den Kohlefasermatten auszutreten. Das heißt, es verdampft quasi aus diesen Kohlefasermatten und bildet damit so eine Art Isolationsschicht. Das verhindert eben, dass dieses Material sehr schnell zerstört wird. Es ist quasi eine Art Isolator außen herum, der die Hitze in gewissem Maße abhält. Das wird aller Wahrscheinlichkeit dazu führen, dass tatsächlich diese Spiegelstruktur, den Wiedereintritt, dann überleben wird.
Und als Ganzes? Oder sind die Vibrationen so stark, dass das Ding schon auseinanderbrechen wird? Oder ist das auch schwer zu sagen?
Letztendlich wird man das aus Modellrechnung nicht mit Sicherheit sagen können. Es könnte sein, dass das allerdings als Ganzes herunterkommt.
Und der alleine ist wie schwer?
Ja, man muss etwa damit rechnen, dass das schwerste Fragment, sprich Spiegel, wahrscheinlich inklusive dieser Messinstrumente, etwa 1,2 Tonnen wiegen wird. Ungefähr.
Das ist ja schon ganz schön erbrocken. Also was wird getan, also vor allem wird das Ding beobachtet?
Richtig.
Sehr intensiv nämlich.
Das wird beobachtet. ROSAT wird, wie jedes andere Objekt im Weltall, was etwa größer 10 cm ist, im niedrigen Weltall, ständig beobachtet von einem US-amerikanischen Überwachungssystem. Das liefert Bahndaten, Bahndatenelemente. Die werden benutzt, um diesen Abstieg des ROSAT jetzt zu verfolgen, zu beobachten. Anhand dieser Bahndatenelemente werden auch die Lebensdauerprognosen gemacht. Wer macht diese Prognosen? Das bekommt ihr hier? Nein, die Prognosen bekommen wir regelmäßig geliefert vom ESOC, vom Europäischen Raumfahrt-Kontrollezentrum in Darmstadt und auch von der TU Braunschweig, sodass wir da also zwei Werte haben, die wir da gegeneinander auch abgleichen können. Die sagen beide im Moment, Anfang November 2011 voraus, dass die...
TU Braunschweig hat ja sich spezialisiert auf diese Weltraumschrott-Problematik.
Genau, man hat sich dort auch darauf spezialisiert.
Und was macht man dann mit diesen Informationen?
Zunächst erst einmal einfach diese Informationen kann man benutzen, natürlich einfach, um erst mal informiert zu sein, wann überhaupt der Satellit herunterkommen wird. Wenn wir in der Phase sind, dass der Satellit, dass dieser Wiedereintritt immer näher rückt, dann muss man tatsächlich etwas genauer hinschauen. Das wird in dem Falle mit internationaler, ja in internationaler Kooperation auch passieren, im Zuge einer sogenannten Reentry-Kampagne. Es gibt eine internationale Organisation, das IADC, Interagency Space Debris Coordination Committee nennt sich das. Das ist ein Zusammenschluss von 12 Raumfahrtagenturen, in dem sehr eng Forschungsergebnisse zum Thema Weltraummüll ausgetauscht werden. Man trifft sich dort einmal im Jahr zu einem drei- bis viertägigen Kongress, wo wirklich die Wissenschaftler zusammengebracht werden und sehr eng miteinander dort ihre Ergebnisse austauschen. Im Rahmen des IADC gibt es eine jährliche sogenannte Reentry-Kampagne. Diese Reentry-Kampagne dient dazu, Codes, Software-Codes, die die Lebensdauer von Satelliten bestimmen, miteinander zu vergleichen, um zu schauen, ob man dort konsistente Ergebnisse hat. Und man macht quasi jedes Jahr eine Testkampagne. Das heißt, im Rahmen dieser Testkampagne wird größtensordnungsmäßig zehn Tage bevor ein Wiedereintritt eines ausgesuchten Objektes stattfindet. In dem Falle wird es dann der ROSAT sein, wird diese Aktion gestartet. Und das ESOC, das Europäische Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum in Darmstadt, dort das Space Debris Office, sammelt dann von Mitgliedern aller zwölf Agenturen, Lebensdauer vorhersagen. Das heißt, es werden größtensordnungsmäßig ein Dutzend verschiedene Wissenschaftler sitzen daran, beobachten den Abstieg des ROSAT, liefern in mehr oder weniger regelmäßigen Abständen Lebensdauerprognosen. Gleichzeitig werden häufiger Messdaten bereitgestellt, typischerweise von amerikanischer Seite aus. Erhöht sich die Frequenz der Bahndatenelemente, der Messdaten, die man hat. Und im Falle des ROSAT wird auch das Deutsche Radar, das Tira, dort Trackingdaten liefern.
Heißt das, dass all diese Wissenschaftlergruppen, unabhängig voneinander, aber auf Basis derselben Daten eine Vorhersage machen? Ja, es geht darum, eine kollektive Intelligenz dazu zu entfachen und da einen Mittelwert zu bilden.
Ja, wenn man so möchte, kann man das so nennen.
Das könnte ja durchaus erfolgreich sein, oder? Gab es da nicht schon Ergebnisse, wie gut das funktioniert?
Ja, tatsächlich ist dann so, aber das weiß man leider erst im Nachhinein, dass sich im Nachhinein zeigt, dass die Vorhersage der Lebensdauer zum Schluss tatsächlich besser ist als die 20 Prozent, von denen wir im Moment ausgehen. Typischerweise wird die Vorhersage dann mit 10 Prozent Unsicherheit oder noch besser.
Aber ist der Mittelwert, was nimmt man dann als die Wahrheit an? Also wenn zwölf Gruppen sagen, also unserer Meinung nach läuft der jetzt noch zwei Wochen, der andere sagt, nö, dann macht es jetzt noch eine Woche, man sammelt das alles, schmeißt das in einen Topf, bildet einen Mittelwert und das glaubt man dann oder was ist da der Prozess?
Man muss dann natürlich genau hinschauen und das dann wirklich bewerten und beurteilen, was dann da jetzt passiert. Also wenn elf sagen, es sind noch sechs Stunden Lebensdauer und eine Lebensdauervorhersage würde sagen, es sind noch 18 Stunden, dann würde man wohl diese 18 Stunden als einen Ausreißer betrachten. Also man muss dann wirklich sehr individuell schauen.
Aber eigentlich geht es um dieses Prinzip, dass man quasi Fehler dadurch außen vor lässt oder außen vor lassen möchte, indem man eben möglichst viele unabhängige Berechnungen hat.
Und für die Wissenschaftler ist das natürlich ein Anreiz, der genaueste zu sein.
Sozusagen auch noch so ein eigener Sport innerhalb der Wissenschaftlergemeinde.
Wenn man so möchte, ja.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das als Ansporn auch wirkt. Aber welche Daten werden jetzt konkret herangezogen? Also das ist die aktuelle Position, das ist quasi das Wissen um Sonnenaktivität.
Genau.
Diese UV-Strahlung wird gemessen.
Na, das sind im Wesentlichen die Hauptwerte. Also die letzten Bahndaten, das heißt Position und Geschwindigkeitswerte, letztendlich das Satelliten und die solare Aktivität.
Und wie serviert das?
Das wird dann kombiniert und natürlich durcheinandergewürfelt mit Atmosphären, Modellen und dann kommt dann zum Schluss eine Zahl raus, die dann halt eben letztendlich die Lebensdauer angibt.
Wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass das jetzt so Anfang November auch in etwa stattfinden wird, ab wann kann man sich denn sicher sein? Also ab wann sind denn diese Vorhersagen so, woran sieht man, dass man sich jetzt sicher sein kann? Also ich meine diese 10-20 Prozent Fehler, die stehen ja jetzt nicht an den Berechnungen noch so mit dran. Oder ist das mehr so eine Interpretationssache, wie sicher man sich jetzt ist?
Also wirklich sicher, wo das Ding runterkommt, sicher, wo ROSAT runterkommt oder sicher, wo ein anderer Satellit runterkommt, kann man nie sein. Auch wenige Stunden vorher nicht. Was man sagen kann ist oder mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen kann, ist der Orbit, in dem er runterkommt. Das ist immer noch ein großer Bereich. Aber viel mehr kann man tatsächlich nicht mit Sicherheit sagen. Im Umkehrschluss heißt das auch, dass niemand eine konkrete Warnung aussprechen kann und sagen kann, das Objekt wird dort oder dort wahrscheinlich wieder eintreten. Was man aber sehr wohl machen kann, ist vorher, ich sag mal Größenordnung vielleicht ein, zwei Tage vorher, wenn man diesen Orbit bestimmt hat und relativ genau weiß, auf welchem Orbit das ist, dann kann man natürlich sehr, sehr große Bereiche der Erde ausschließen. Wenn dieser letzte Orbit, sagen wir nicht, über Mittelamerika führt, nicht über Europa führt oder über andere Gebiete, dann weiß man bereits, dort kann der Satellit auch nicht mehr niedergehen. Also letztendlich kann man, wie gesagt, nur über dieses Ausschlussprinzip sehr große Bereiche der Erde ausschließen.
Nur mal so zum Verständnis. Ich meine, jetzt beobachtet man, der sinkt, der sinkt, der sinkt, der sinkt. Was hatten wir? 400 Meter pro Tag steht jetzt an. So, in der Schlussphase wird er dann sehr viel schneller fallen. Was wird man dann noch beobachten, bevor es jetzt wird? Also, wie schnell fällt er voraussichtlich, bis er wirklich anfängt zu glühen? Also, was ist... Die Glühphase ist jetzt wirklich das Allerletzte.
Genau.
Ab da fällt er eigentlich auch nur noch.
Genau, ab dann fällt er.
Also, das heißt, man will jetzt auch schon, bevor er anfängt zu glühen, will man eigentlich schon relativ genau wissen, wo er anfängt zu glühen. Weil danach kann man eh nix mehr retten.
Ja, aber auch, wie gesagt, auch das wird man nicht wissen können, wo er anfängt zu glühen. Also, wenn er, sagen wir mal so, die Größenordnung 120, 130 Kilometer erreicht hat, dann überlebt er nur noch einen Orbit oder etwas mehr als einen Orbit. Ah, okay.
Das heißt, er kann schon noch einmal um die ganze Erde herumfliegen. Und ist denn der Satellit über seine gesamten Flugbahnen bis zum Auftreffen komplett beobachtbar?
Nein. Das hängt dann zu dem Zeitpunkt von dem aktuellen Orbit wirklich ab und natürlich von der Verteilung dieser Überwachungsnetzwerke. Also die meisten Radare der USA, des amerikanischen Netzwerkes stehen nun mal in den USA. Wenn der Orbit zu dem Zeitpunkt so liegt, dass er die Sichtbarkeit dieser Radare oder diesen Sichtbereich dieser Radare nicht durchfliegt, können die Radarien auch nicht beobachten.
Aber Radar kommt ja erst zum Tragen, wenn es Orbit sehr viel niedriger ist oder werden jetzt auch schon Radare eingesetzt?
Der wird auch jetzt von diesem Radar-Netzwerk geträgt.
Aber jetzt ist er dann auch noch so weit oben, dass es eigentlich immer irgendjemanden gibt, der ihn gerade trecken kann oder gibt es jetzt auch schon Blindspots, wo einfach Radar gerade nicht hinkommt?
Das ist auch im Moment der Fall. Also all diese Satelliten sind nur zu bestimmten Zeiten sichtbar, dann verschwinden sie mal wieder daraus, bis sie wieder sichtbar werden. Herr Drümper hat das auch schon erwähnt, dass der ROSAT die Kontrollstation in Weilheim etwa fünfmal am Tag überflogen hat. Das heißt, fünfmal am Tag war er für Weilheim sichtbar. Genau dieselbe Situation haben wir mit einem Überwachungsradar. Er ist ein paar Mal am Tag sichtbar für dieses Radar, überfliegt den Sichtbereich dieses Radars und verschwindet dann wieder.
Aber es gibt ja mehrere Radars.
Es gibt durchaus mehrere, aber selbst wenn das so wäre, dass er ständig sichtbar ist, man muss ihn nicht ständig verfolgen.
Ich versuche nur so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie gut man ihn überhaupt beobachten kann. Man hängt ja auch davon ab, ob man rechtzeitig einschätzen kann, welchen Fallbereich er jetzt tatsächlich anstrebt.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist halt eben die Situation, mit der man da zu tun hat. Aktuell ist es wahrscheinlich auch so, dass dieser Satellit auch nicht bei jedem Überflug unbedingt dort eine neue Bahnbestimmung stattfindet. Man weiß ja, auf welchem Orbit er sich befindet. Man muss die Bahndaten eines Satelliten oder eines anderen Trommerteils nicht bei jedem Überflug wirklich wieder neu bestimmen. Sondern die Unsicherheit in diesen Bahndaten, die wächst im Laufe der Zeit an und irgendwann muss man die eben aktualisiert werden, dann gibt es einen neuen Bahndatensatz. Zum Schluss versucht man halt eben möglichst häufig Bahndaten zu haben, deswegen zum Beispiel auch der Einsatz des TIRRA-Radars, wo man dann wirklich versuchen will...
Was ist das Radar?
TIRRA ist ein Radar, das wird betrieben von der Fraunhofer-Gesellschaft. Das ist ein Forschungsradar, was hier in Wachtberg steht, nee, Bonn. TIRRA steht für Tracking and Imaging-Radar, ist also ein Großradar, ein Forschungsradar, was tatsächlich zum Trecken von Weltraumobjekten benutzt werden kann oder benutzt wird.
Das kommt auch zum Einsatz?
Das wird dann zum Einsatz kommen, genau, und man wird dann halt eben versuchen, in den letzten Tagen jeden möglichen Überflug des ROSAT mit diesem Radar zu beobachten.
Vielleicht mal im Vergleich zu diesen unkontrollierten Abstürzen, wie läuft es denn, wenn es kontrollierter abgeht?
Aktuell z.B. kontrolliert die Wiedereintritte, sind die Wiedereintritte des europäischen Raumtransporters ATV. Da geht man so vor, dass man im Prinzip diesen Transporter über kontrollierte Manöver die Bahnhöhe erst verringert und ihn dann über ein Bremsmanöver verzögert, um ihn auf eine. Wiedereintritts-Trajektorie zu bringen. Diese Wiedereintritts-Bahn wird so gewählt, dass sie typischerweise über dem Meer liegt, weil man dort natürlich keine Gefahr hat, jemanden zu treffen, besiedeltes Gebiet zu treffen. Meistens wird es über den Pazifik gemacht, weil dort entsprechend eine genügend große Fläche vorhanden ist, über der man dieses Objekt dann zum Absturz, zum Niedergang bringen kann.
Aber Schiffe und Boote wurden jetzt auch noch nicht in Mitleidenschaft gezogen. Es wurde eigentlich überhaupt noch nie etwas in Mitleidenschaft gezogen, oder?
Es hat bisher meiner Kenntnis nach noch keinen ernsthaften Sachschaden oder Personenschaden gegeben. Weder bei kontrollierten noch bei unkontrollierten Eintritten. Und wie gesagt, die unkontrollierten Eintritte, 27.000 Tonnen oder etwas mehr als 27.000 Tonnen, sind bereits heruntergegangen.
Nicht unerheblich?
Nein.
Das heißt, es besteht eigentlich auch eine gute Chance, dass das jetzt mit dem ROSAT durchaus gimpflich abläuft?
Aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach wird das wohl so sein. Es gibt natürlich ein gewisses Restrisiko, das kann man nicht ausschließen.
Aber trotzdem sind ja jetzt, ich meine, wenn man das jetzt so intensiv beobachtet, irgendwann wird man das ja dann wissen. Irgendwann wird man ja zumindest eine Ahnung haben, wo er jetzt wirklich runtergeht. Kann dann der Absturz als solcher auch wirklich beobachtet werden oder ist das dann auch nur Zufall? Beziehungsweise kann man aus diesen letzten Daten, wenn auch nur im Nachhinein, genau errechnen, wo er denn wirklich runtergekommen sein wird oder wo die Reste in etwa verteilt sein müssten?
Ja, also dass man den Absturz beobachtet, das wäre reiner Zufall. Also man hat keine Möglichkeit, dort irgendwie zu reagieren und dorthin zu fahren, zu fliegen oder so.
Also weil man einfach nicht rechtzeitig diesen, also man weiß es einfach nicht früh genug, um irgendwas in die Nähe bringen zu können?
Genau, wie gesagt, letztendlich weiß man auch den genauen Ort nicht. Man wird halt eben nur diesen Orbit sagen. Also man müsste sich dann entlang dieses ganzen Orbits verteilen oder wie auch immer.
Und der ist lang.
Der ist sehr lang und der geht über Meer, über Wüsten, unbesiedeltes Gebiet. Also das ist unrealistisch. Das erste, was man wahrscheinlich wissen wird, ist, dass er nicht mehr da ist. Man versucht den Satelliten ja zu beobachten und wenn man diesen Wiedereintritt nicht direkt beobachten kann, dann muss man indirekt darauf schließen, dass er irgendwann nicht mehr da ist. Und das kann man eben, wenn man einen Überflug erwarten würde. Das heißt, man weiß, der ROSAT müsste jetzt in den nächsten drei Minuten, in den nächsten fünf Minuten, über meinen Radar drüber kommen, ich schaue hoch und ich sehe nichts mehr. Dann muss er weg sein.
Der Satellit ist auch komplett tot, also der gibt keinen Mucks mehr von sich.
Richtig, ROSAT gibt keinen Mucks mehr von sich, der ist komplett passiviert. Erst im Nachhinein wird man dann, also wie gesagt, man wird zuerst wissen, er muss runter gegangen sein, irgendwo muss der Wiedereintritt geschehen sein. Erst im Nachhinein wird man dann die ungefähren Wiedereintrittspunkte bestimmen können. Das sind Werte, die dann auch wieder von der amerikanischen Seite übermittelt werden.
Wie muss man sich denn jetzt diesen Absturz dann als solchen, also wie geht es den Satelliten so? Also ich meine, irgendwann wird die Atmosphäre dann immer dichter, es wird dann immer heißer, Sachen fangen an zu glühen, bzw. bestimmte Dinge fangen dann nicht ausreichend an zu glühen. Was passiert so mit der ganzen Materie, also was ist überhaupt so, ich meine, wir haben jetzt über einiges gesprochen, was nicht so ohne weiteres verglüht, aber es wird ja auch genug Sachen geben, die diese Hitze einfach nicht überstehen. Wie ist denn das so verteilt?
Ja, also man kann so sagen, etwa bei 120 Kilometern, hatte ich ja bereits erwähnt, überlegt dieser Satellit nur noch etwa einen Orbit. Er sinkt dann relativ schnell in die Erdatmosphäre rein, also diese Orbit, diese mehr oder weniger Kreisbahn verändert sich dann und wenn er dann so etwa 110 Kilometer in Orbithöhe erreicht, dann fängt er bereits an zu fragmentieren. Also dort können einzelne Objekte abbrechen.
Also es reißt ihn auseinander und so.
Genau, also ich denke mal so typisch werden zum Beispiel Solarpanele, die nun abstehen, die dann abbrechen können oder abreißen können. Bei diesem Wiedereintritt wird halt eben letztendlich auch die gesamte Bahnenergie umgewandelt in Wärmeenergie. Das heißt er fängt tatsächlich an zu glühen wie so ein kleiner Feuerball. Der Hauptbereich, in dem der Satellit dann fragmentiert, liegt so, sagen wir mal, zwischen 90 Kilometern und vielleicht 60 Kilometern, 50 Kilometern. Also in diesem Bereich zerbricht ein Satellit mehr oder weniger in Einzelteile. Er wird dabei von Orbitalgeschwindigkeit ganz extrem abgebremst. Orbitalgeschwindigkeit ist in dem Falle 27.000 Kilometer pro Stunde. Der Satellit erfährt dabei eben eine sehr große Aufheizung. Das Maximum der Aufheizung liegt so in etwa bei 80 Kilometern Höhe. Und kurz danach tritt dann auch der Zeitpunkt auf, wo der Satellit die höchste Verzögerung erfährt. Ich hab mir mal den Spaß gemacht und das mal für den ROSAT mal ausgerechnet. Also er erreicht eine durchschnittliche Verzögerungswerte zwischen 5 und 7G. Durchschnittlich. Um das mal in eine Perspektive zu rücken, wenn du mit einem Supersportwagen auf einer Rennstrecke fährst, mit Keramikbremsen und haust dort voll in die Bremse, dann erreichst du 1G Verzögerungswerte. Der Satellit erreicht größtenordnungsmäßig das 5-7-fache und das auf eine Dauer von mehreren Minuten. Das sind also gewaltige Verzögerungswerte. Hinzu kommen natürlich noch lokal möglicherweise höhere Verzögerungswerte.
Also also als ob man gegen eine Wand fährt.
So in etwa, genau.
Also die gibt ein bisschen nach die Wand, aber auch nicht sehr.
Genau. Das heißt, er erfährt also sehr hohe Verzögerungswerte. Ja, und dabei zerbröselt er, Metalle schmelzen, Platinen verbrennen, also letztendlich zerlegt er sich dort dadurch, dass er wegschmilzt, dass Teile wegschmelzen, beziehungsweise Teile einfach dem mechanischen Belastungen nicht mehr standhalten und abbrechen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Ingredienzien, die irgendwann mal in die Elektronik geflossen sind, die werden jetzt eigentlich genauso feinsäuberlich wieder der Erde zurückgegeben.
Genau.
Die können sich wieder einordnen, wo sie mal hergekommen sind.
Richtig, die zerlegen sich da und verteilen sich dann in der Atmosphäre als Alzener-Atome. Ja, und dann tritt eben dieser Pfahlsreste überleben, wovon wir beim ROSAT dann ausgehen müssen, drehten die dann schließlich in die Erdatmosphäre ein und fallen mehr oder weniger im freien Fall dann zum Schluss herunter.
Und das war's dann mit dem ROSAT?
Das war's dann mit dem ROSAT, ja.
Gibt es denn noch weitere Objekte, die so in der nächsten Zeit auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise begleitet werden müssen, weil man sich nicht so sicher ist, wo sie jetzt eigentlich runterkommen? Es war ja bei den meisten so am Anfang und jetzt läuft es halt langsam aus, dadurch dass eben bei den Missionen von Anfang an darauf geachtet wird. Wie lange begleitet uns das Thema noch, dass Dinge unkontrolliert herunterkommen?
Das wird uns noch sehr lange begleiten. Ich meine, es sind noch eine ganze Masse Objekte oben, verschiedenste Raketenoberstufen, verschiedene andere Satelliten, die müssen auch alle irgendwann mal herunterkommen. Und wenn man die Spanne der Lebensdauer dort sieht, Objekte, die in 800 Kilometern Höhe beispielsweise befinden, die können durchaus Lebensdauern von 150 Jahren und mehr haben. Also wenn dort ein Objekt sich auf einem Orbit jetzt befindet, dann hat man in 100, 150 Jahren oder noch länger noch mit dieser Problematik in gewissem Sinne zu tun, wenn man keine Gegenmaßnahmen ergreift.
Wie viel bleibt von diesen Oberstufen üblicherweise übrig?
Auch das ist in diesem Bereich, dass etwa 10 bis 40 Prozent der Masse übrig bleiben können. Es gibt so ein paar Objekte, die ganz typischerweise eigentlich dann überbleiben, was man auch schon gefunden hat. Das sind beispielsweise Treibstofftanks, die aus Stahl bestehen oder Druckbehälter, die aus Titan bestehen. Man hat auch schon Brennkammern von Triebwerken gefunden. Also typischerweise Objekte, die aus...
Wo sind die dann so gefunden worden?
Ja, das was man findet, hat man meistens in nicht besiedelten oder dünn besiedelten Gegenden gefunden.
Tundra, Sibirien, Wüste.
Genau, so was zum Beispiel. Es kommt auch schon mal vor oder ist auch schon vorgekommen, dass Objekte in dünn besiedelten Gebieten irgendwo niedergegangen sind, wo man es dann relativ schnell gefunden hat. Aber das meiste geht tatsächlich in unbesiedelten Gebieten.
Geblüßt hinterlogen?
Meines Wissens nach nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, aber das Interesse daran dürfte doch nicht gering sein. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt was findet, kommt das dann gleich ins Museum oder wird das dann auch gleich wissenschaftlich ausgewertet? Ist das nicht so interessant, ist das nicht so spannend? Ich meine, man kann ja sagen, ha, jetzt können wir hier mal an dem Tag gucken, wie gut er das überlebt hat und so.
Ja, ich denke letztendlich ist das nicht so spannend. Der Find-A-Lohn besteht vielleicht in einer Pressemitteilung, wo man mit einem Foto dann auftaucht.
Okay, immerhin. Aber das wissenschaftliche Interesse daran ist jetzt nicht so groß. Es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt sich die Objekte noch mal gerne anschauen möchte, um darauf wiederum Rückschlüsse auf, weiß nicht, möchte man denn, also lässt sich das überhaupt, ist das überhaupt erstrebenswert? Wäre es vielleicht, aber ist es überhaupt möglich, Dinge so zu bauen, dass sie dann besser verglühen? Das steht wahrscheinlich so hinten an, hinter den ganzen anderen Bedürfnissen.
Gut, besser verglühen, man kann natürlich versuchen, über die Wahl der Materialien, die man verwendet, darauf Einfluss zu nehmen. Andererseits ist die Materialwahl natürlich über die Aufgabe eines Objektes, was man an der Technologie bestimmt. Also ich kann nicht einen Drucktank aus Schaumstoff bauen, das geht einfach nicht. Dafür brauche ich ein Material wie Tizan, daran kann man nichts ändern.
Und das hält einfach gut.
So ist es, ja.
Ja, Manuel, haben wir noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen?
Ja, ich glaube nicht.
Gut, dann sage ich nochmal vielen Dank. Und das war es hier bei dem zweiten Teil zum Thema ROSAT. Und ja, hier geht es bald wieder weiter mit anderen Themen bei Raumzeit. Und ich bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und sage tschüss, bis bald.